big news this morning on the fight
against coronavirus pfizer announcing
promising results from a late stage
trial
of their vaccine suggesting it may be 90
percent effective joining us now is
health and human services secretary alex
azar
mr secretary great to have you on this
morning on that news but first we've
just confirmed
that hud secretary ben carson has tested
positive for coronavirus
we're told he's in good spirits we wish
him well we also
have seen reports that you were with him
for an election night viewing party
where some fear that this could be a
spreader event how are you doing and
have you been tested
uh well i actually did not see secretary
carson at the election night party and i
kept
face covering on at all times and worked
to maintain social distance following
exactly the types of advice that
i give to the american people every time
i can talk to them i wish
secretary carson well absolutely we all
do we're here we're hearing he's doing
okay this morning
uh we look for an update on that
meanwhile this vaccine is huge news
you've seen reaction on wall street did
you see this
coming and what can you tell us it means
for the fight
against this virus well today is a
really historic day in the history of
public health you know when
when i pulled together operation warp
speed under the direction of president
trump
the best people said that we could do
would be to get vaccines in 12 to 18
months and dr
fauci and others said that would be
remarkable and historic and here we are
10 months from this virus hitting our
shores
and we have a vaccine that's proving 90
percent effective
that's thanks to president trump's
leadership it's thanks to operation warp
speed and
i talked to him just this morning as i
do most mornings and he's
he's really excited about the prospect
that we'll be able to save american
lives not just through the vaccines
that we have many vaccines not just this
one that we've invested in
but also therapeutics mr secretary i'm
curious do you know
timeline everybody's wondering when can
we get this vaccine
when will it come to market yeah so
pfizer will have to now pull together
their data and submit it to the fda
where it will
undergo an independent review process
there and so it of course has to be
authorized by the fda so
you should be thinking in the several
week time period both for the submission
and then review
by fda of the data thanks to operation
warp speed we've actually guaranteed
receipt of fda authorized vaccine from
pfizer
100 million doses that we purchased for
about two billion dollars with an option
for another 500 million more
and those will start in increments of
about 20 million 20 million doses pfizer
has said
uh beginning in late november and
continuing monthly thereafter
mr secretary the governor of new york
state
went on an interview this morning
reacting to this this breaking news
and he suggested somehow that this is
bad timing to
learn of the results of this vaccine
listen
the bad news is that it's about two
months before
joe biden takes over and that means this
administration is going to be
implementing a vaccine
plan they're basically going to have the
private providers do it
and that's going to leave out all sorts
of communities that were left out the
first time
when cove had ravaged them hard to
believe anybody would think
that it's bad news to get these
wonderful results from a late stage
trial of a vaccine
mr azar i'll let you respond
specifically to that he's making the
point that well that means that donald
trump is in charge of distribution
so react to the governor and also tell
us about how it'll be distributed
well it's just absolutely unconscionable
that somebody would want to delay a
vaccine to the american people that's
safe and effective just for political
partisan reasons but
here's the really interesting thing is
operation warp speed is working
very closely with governor cuomo's
health commissioner dr howard zucker and
his team
because guess who's actually in charge
of distributing within any state
the governor is and his team's doing a
really good job working with us
and they can set up a distribution
system and prioritization within their
state
but you know this is more
one-size-fits-all approach is that only
the government can do things
that's not what was operation warp speed
which was public private partnership if
we had relied only on government to do
things
nothing would be getting delivered right
now instead we've got to go for breaking
news but are you getting any word from
governors like cuomo that they're going
to try to stop the distribution of this
under this presidency no the other
governors that we're working with are
excited and they want to be in charge of
the distribution they're working in
partnership with us and we've got a
great plan that leverages
the finest distribution system in the
world to make sure vaccine gets where it
needs to go
safely and effectively does that include
cuomo well it includes his staff he
ought to talk to them and maybe learn
what their plans are
got it mr secretary really appreciate
you coming on we've got some breaking
news thank